when you start to think about uh the
macro environment right now bitcoin is
down 70
uh i think that you have lived through
maybe four or five different drawdowns
of 80 plus percent um what is similar to
past market drawdowns and what is
different about this one compared to
those past market drawdowns
i think in the past there was
a definite
lack of liquidity going on so you know
mount gox was the only exchange around
and it was incredibly buggy and
wasn't
suitable for making markets and
so when it started to blow up you had a
pretty predictable fall
in the price um other exchanges that
were dominant like bit max and others
were
were run um without much thought to
um concern about
hewing to regulatory guidelines let's
say
i think when sailor first started buying
bitcoin
he made the comment that maybe 50
million
a day in volume was actual
bitcoin the rest was wash trading you
know bitcoin has had a wash trading
problem for years you know exchanges
trading for the in them owned their own
accounts to create stimulated volume
you see that in the nasdaq market all
the time you know nasdaq is a network of
dealers right it's not like the new york
stock exchange where you have a
specialist at this post
making a market you have a network and
and that nasdaq is
for years guilty of wash trading amongst
themselves to create the painting the
tape and all these other techniques to
create the illusion of volume and to
manufacture prices and bitcoin had this
problem for years and so when the
sentiment changed you'd have an 80
drawdown because there's just no volume
there was no volume now what's different
here is that over the past let's call it
the michael sailor era of the past
several years
the volume has become legitimate and the
demand is legitimate and so the markets
are legitimate and but the the issue
here would be the layering on top of
this market of these derivatives or d
phi and cross collateralization so
that's created um
uh a a an obstacle uh for for good price
discovery so that that would be the
difference but the net effect is the
same you know people
always of course ask me and ask you and
ask others for price predictions and
it's um it's an incredibly volatile
asset so it really is
incredibly difficult to make a price
direction other than just that
prediction other than to say that
what i've been saying for 11 years i can
i'll tell you the direction of bitcoin
it's up you know if you hold it for
three or f you know maybe three and a
half years anyone who's held it for
three and a half years or four years
is in the black right so if you've got a
time frame of which is not a long time
frame three and a half four years you're
going to be in the black
but i think that would be the the main
difference is that also you know in this
environment i when i was at the bitcoin
miami
22
the you know the conference the
difference between that conference and
let's say conference from 10 years ago
was the quality of the suits
right so the people on stage are wearing
you know 3 000 suits back 11 years ago
10 years ago people would show up and
torn t-shirts and there were coders and
you know rarely came out of their
basement but it's the same kind of
struggle to come to terms with this
emerging asset class
and in a lot of ways it's the same uh
you just have a higher grade of
speculator you have of course um the
amount of money that's been flooding the
system has increased every year for many
years now i mean we got to
the the the central banks have fina have
decided within the last six months to
to raise rates uh and and really put an
end to a 40-year
bull market in the bond market um so on
the macro side this is the first time
bitcoin has faced a rising interest rate
environment
uh which causes on the macro side a huge
shift in the funds uh you see for
example something like the russian ruble
is the strongest performing currency in
the world in 2022 because it's commodity
based i think
starting in february with the the russia
ukraine conflict we saw the end of a
40-year bull market in bonds and
financialization in the beginning of a
secular inflationary
move in global markets that'll be
tied to commodities you know commodities
were not a big factor for 40 years it
was financialization interest rates
extend and pretend just create more
bonds lower lower you know the coupon
rate extend the maturity that's the way
the world worked for 40 years and now
we're in a new world where suddenly the
price of stuff like energy and food it
cannot be hidden anymore it's actually
hitting people's bottom line and that's
not going to change anytime soon that's
a secular shift in the inflation in the
economy in in the globe that's going to
be with us for years not a few months
and so that's something that is new for
bitcoin
um and
ultimately it's going to do well in that
environment because
as people begin to understand that the
financialized world is crumbling uh
having this you know i've often i often
say bitcoin is a risk off
investment it's not a risk on it's risk
off uh this is where you put your safe
haven cash it's hard to make that case
with the volatility the way it is but
when you have something
for all the other reasons it's
unconfiscatable unsensible immutable you
know it makes sense and it makes a lot
of sense for a billion or two billion
people
out there that have been unbanked that's
where the growth's going to come that's
where the adoption is happening
so that those are the changes some some
differences some similarities
when you think of the macro environment
the fed says they're going to continue
to raise interest rates they're going to
conduct quantitative tightening they're
going to get a soft landing inflation
will come down everyone calm down and
all will be good in the world
how crazy are they and how off are they
in their thought process that they can
actually get inflation down and not push
us into a recession
you know it's uh as i said i think this
is a kind of a follow-up to what we were
just saying there so
um the fed is still thinking like the
world is similar to the way it's been
for 40 years you know starting with
greenspan you had the so-called green
span put you know every time markets
came down greenspan would flood the
market with more cash and lower interest
rates and that had they went through
bernanke johnny allen jay powell
the activist fed
this the model has been with us for 40
years
and that there's no problem that can't
be solved by money printing what
happened in february
24th
with russia ukraine now
is that that model is dead and
the price
determining factor for prices is shifted
from
the new york fed or from the
fed
to
the east
to russia russia china iran india
uh central america south america brazil
those countries are going to be
determining
prices going forward
and
so the and the fed only makes
can only operate if the world is on a
globalized
us dollar standard but that's no longer
the case you know on february 26
two days after
russia ukraine conflict the fed seized
like 600
billion i think or million
billion in russian reserves
so we know china looked at that and said
you mean our reserves aren't safe
so
um
that was a huge
you know
self
owned you know that was that was one of
the stupidest things that anyone could
have done so now we're on a we're in a
new world and i just think jay powell
and these guys and janet yellen they're
thinking they haven't adjusted yet but
you know markets are are cruel you know
and the market price ultimately
works his way into reality
and that gas price isn't going down you
know we're talking 10 11 12 15 a gallon
for gas in the united states
you know uh in that that
do the math pop that that's not gonna
that that's a fundamental shift in the
in this
standard of living
for the united states that's just that's
just the fact because we don't have the
ability to control these markets and
prices anymore because nobody people are
dumping the dollar
the dollar is not going to be world
reserve currency and the guys with the
actual
energy
are in control
so how we how are we gonna fight that um
and all the rhetoric coming out of the
the uk and these other countries seems
like people are totally tone deaf to
this reality uh
germany or let's look at another
industry for example the esg industry
you know the the climate change industry
the the the move toward renewables
well
you know that's that's completely blown
out of the water germany which was
heading toward 100 renewable is now
going back to coal
like all these countries are going back
to coal now
because
because of what's happening in the
energy markets
and so that's that's just a total shift
so i mean you're a bully i believe
you're a millennial and pomp and you
know i i think of it as being one of the
unluckiest generations ever in history
you know you kind of grew up dude
through 9 11 you've been through the
2008 crisis the subprime crisis and now
you're going to watch the us dollar lose
world reserve currency pump you know you
guys and your brothers are really the
you got you you lost the generational
lottery i can say that